Well, if you've got a Bible, please turn with me to Matthew chapter 16.
It's also there in your worship guides.
Matthew chapter 16 will read verse 13 down to the end of the chapter.
So verse 13 to verse 28.
Now when Jesus came into the district of Caesarea Philippi, he asked the disciples,
who do people say that the Son of man is? And they said, some say John the Baptist,
others say Elijah, and others Jeremiah or one of the prophets.
He said to them, who do you say that I am?
Simon Peter replied, you are the Christ, the Son of the living God.
And Jesus answered him, blessed are you Simon Barjona, for flesh and blood has not revealed
this to you but my Father who is in heaven. And I tell you, you are Peter. And on this rock,
I will build my church and the gates of hell shall not prevail against it.
I will give you the keys of the kingdom of heaven and whatever you bind on earth shall
be bound in heaven. And whatever you loose on earth shall be loosed in heaven.
Then he strictly charged the disciples to tell no one that he was the Christ.
From that time, Jesus began to show his disciples that he must go to Jerusalem and
suffer many things from the elders and the chief priests and the scribes and be killed.
And on the third day, be raised. And Peter took him aside and began to rebuke him saying,
Far be it from you Lord, this shall never happen to you. But he turned and said to Peter,
Get behind me Satan, you are a hindrance to me, for you are not setting your mind on the
things of God but on the things of man. Then Jesus told his disciples, if anyone would come
after me, let him deny himself and take up his cross and follow me. For whoever would save his
life will lose it. But whoever loses his life for my sake will find it. For what will it profit a
man if he gains the whole world and forfeits his soul? Or what shall a man give in return for his
soul? For the Son of man is going to come with his angels in the glory of his Father.
And then he will repay each person according to what he has done.
Truly, truly I say to you, there are some standing here who will not taste death
until they see the Son of man coming in his kingdom. This is the word of the Lord. Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that you would open our eyes that we might hold wonderful things in your word.
Or by your spirit, I pray that you would show us more of Jesus
and make us willing to follow wherever he leads. In his name we pray. Amen.
Well, many wonderful things come to mind when I think about this past year in the start of
Trinity Fellowship, encouraging stories, answered prayers, but that's not to say it's all been
easy. There have been times when I've kind of felt like the proverbial dog that finally caught the car.
You know what I'm saying? So you've got the dog who's kind of like sitting there on the side of
the road and he's ready for the car to come out. And when the car comes finally,
he chases after it. He's barking, snapping at the tires and does that with car after car.
And then the question is, well, what happens? What's he going to do when he finally catches
the car? And sometimes the saying is followed with a very bleak statement and that is,
the car always wins. And so when it came to this church getting started, like, you know,
for years, church planting has been on my heart and on my mind. And I've seen cars go by, so to
speak, and I've even chased after a few. And then finally, we caught the thing. Now what?
How in the world do you start a church? How do you establish a church so that it
stays over the long haul? And even the question sometimes arises, like, will the car win?
And where do you go with these questions as we think about the harder aspects, maybe? Well,
we could run to books about church planting or maybe conferences. We could learn from the
experiences of others and I'm sure we'll get a lot of good ideas from those things. They have
some value. But this morning, I want us to take I want to take us somewhere that is far more important
than any of that. And it's the promise of Jesus we've just read in Matthew chapter 16 verse 18,
right there in the middle of that verse when he says, I will build my church. The church belongs
to Jesus. And Jesus has promised to build his church. As the psalmist said long ago, he said,
unless the Lord builds the house, those who build it labor in vain. You know, I've been so encouraged,
like with with many of you, you started off coming talking about this church or that church or your
church. But you started saying along through the year, my church, or you started saying things like
our church. And that that is wonderful. It's encouraging that there's a sense of belonging
and ownership there. But at the end of the day, all of us need to remember,
this is the Lord's church. It's also been encouraging to see how so many of like really
thrown themselves into the work and how the Lord has released gifts within the life of the church.
And I want to say, thank you. But at the end of the day, it is not our hard work that builds
the church. It is the Lord who builds his church. And church planting is an opportunity
to participate in what he is doing. Julia and I had the opportunity a few years ago
to move to West Africa and to live there amongst church planters who were working there.
And it was it was so thrilling in so many ways. And we learned so much. And I by specifically
remember one conversation, it was with the kind of the sort of first pioneer church planter who
went into this particular area and planted a church and like from that church, they were
seeing dozens of churches planted across the Sahel Desert in West Africa. And I remember talking to
him about what was going on. He was sharing with me about it. And he all of a sudden started giggling.
And he said, you know what? He said, sometimes I just feel like the like the mouse on the back
of the elephant. I was like, what are you talking about? He said, you know, the mouse in the
back of the elephant, you know, he's they're running through the desert together and the
mouse says to the elephant, look how much dust we're kicking up. Like he says, that's what
I feel like. So they were seeing lots of amazing things. Churches planted right the way across the
region. But he knew it was not him who was doing it. It was the Lord and they were getting to
participate in that. You know, we've seen some dust kicked up this first year at Trinity. And I
hope we see a lot more kicked up in the years to come. Let's remember this is the Lord's
work. Of course, there's work to do, but we cannot trust in our strategies or gifts or finances or
our tenacity or anything like that. Our trust must be in the Lord. Let's get specific with it. So for
the next few moments, I want us to look at this this passage we read and just press into that to
see that our confidence must be first of all being the person of Jesus. And secondly, our
confidence must be in the work of Jesus. And then lastly, I want us to see that our confidence
must be in the way of Jesus. Unfortunately, we're not going to cover everything here in the passage.
So if you have any questions, you know, about the papacy or anything like that,
Dwight would be more than happy to answer them. I'm so glad you're here.
But let's get on with it. So our confidence must be in the person of Jesus, first of all.
So who is this Jesus who promised to build his church? Well, that's the first part of what our text
is addressing. So you look in verses 13 down to verse 20, that kind of first paragraph there.
Jesus has gathered his disciples in this place called Caesarea Philippi. And the conversation
that they have is a real watershed moment in the gospel of Matthew and in the ministry of Jesus
because it deals with his identity. And it begins with this important question. What is it?
Who do people say that the Son of Man is? The disciples started sharing some of the more popular
theories of the day. And people said, well, some say you're John the Baptist. You can look back
in Matthew. And this is what Herod thought. Herod had John the Baptist executed. And he was
fearful that John the Baptist had come back from the dead. Others say you're Elijah or Jeremiah
or one of the prophets. You know, Israel had experienced hundreds of years of silence. And
now you have a teacher in Jesus who's speaking with authority, the authority of a prophet.
I wonder what responses Jesus would get today if he asks that question in our kind of context.
You know, the prophet responses still around with different religious groups that are out there
who think that Jesus is a prophet, but just a prophet. You take a faith like Islam or something
like that. There are others out there who think that Jesus is just a myth, despite mounds of
historical evidence showing that he was a real person who lived, walked among us, died, rose again.
There are those who think he was maybe just like a religious leader or philosopher, revolutionary.
But when you actually look at his teaching, there's no room for just thinking he's merely a
teacher. So who is he? Well, Jesus makes this question then personal to the disciples.
Isn't just like, what do people out there say? He says to them, but who do you say that I am?
Peter on behalf of the disciples speaks up and he says, you are the Christ,
the Son of the living God. This is a huge moment up to this point. Matthew, the narrator of
the Gospel of Matthew is the only one who's spoken of Christ as the Christ. As he's like
writing down what's happening. This is the first time that this confession is uttered aloud in public.
So this is this massive moment as he says that he's the Christ. Jesus then fully affirms what
Peter's just said, saying that this is a revelation that's come from God himself. He says,
blessed are you, Simon Barjona, for flesh and blood has not revealed this to you,
but my Father who is in heaven. So what does it mean to say that Jesus is the Christ,
the Son of the living God? Well, Christ is not his last name. When we say Jesus Christ,
it's a title. It's the kind of Greek version of the Hebrew word Messiah. It means anointed one.
So like in the Old Testament of scriptures, you have prophets and priests and kings who were anointed
by God to fulfill the calling that they had been given. But God also promised that he was
going to raise up not just another anointed one, but the anointed one. If you look at 2 Samuel,
chapter 7, for example, God promises to raise up a king in Israel who would reign forever.
In Psalm 2, it speaks of the Lord's anointed as being his son. Daniel 7, it speaks about the
Son of Man being given dominion over all the earth and how his kingdom will never be destroyed.
This is who Jesus is. He is the promised king who reigns over all the earth and his reign will never
cease. And the extent of his authority stretches beyond what anybody could have seen at this point.
Beyond what Peter knew in his confession, because this book ends with Jesus gathering
his disciples together one final time. And he tells them that he has absolute authority
over everything. So Matthew 28, verse 19, Jesus says, all authority in heaven and on earth
has been given to me. He reigns over all of it. He's the Son of God.
Who do you say that he is? Well, after I spoke at a church one time, a sweet elderly Christian
lady called me over and she held out her hand to shake mine. And I thought, you know, this is one
of those shakes where they've got a bit of money bundled up in their hand. I was ready to shake her
hand. I leaned over to shake her hand and then I felt what was in her hand. And she said something,
if I'll never forget, she said, everybody needs a little Jesus in their life. And she put a little
Jesus in my hand. Now, this is no criticism of her. Please don't hear that. I've got more admiration
for somebody who speaks up and says something to those who would say nothing at all, but could also
say, nobody's taking a picture of this, are they? You don't need a little Jesus in your life.
You don't. You know, in our cultural context, people might answer Jesus' question with, well, Jesus
is Lord. He's my personal Lord and Savior. Although we say he's Lord, we may end up though treating
him as though he was a little part of our lives. Maybe important, but nevertheless, on the margins,
we are at the center and he's out there on the margins somewhere ready to help us when
we might need it. We end up treating Jesus as a means to whatever ends we're aiming at anyway.
We're the Lord of our own lives. And if a little Jesus can help, then I'll have a little Jesus to
add into the mix, too. But that's not who he is. Jesus is the Christ. Everything in the universe
exists by him and for him. He is before all things and in him all things hold together. And he is the
head of the body of the church. And one day, every knee will bow and every tongue will confess
that Jesus Christ is Lord, the glory of God, the Father. What's that Jesus doing today?
He's building his church. He's building it on this apostolic confession. He is the Christ,
the Son of the living God. He is gathering those who are ready to confess that he is Lord and live
under his reign. So who do you say that he is? Well, I pray that the same God who opened the
eyes of Peter to see and confess that he is the Christ will do the same with all of us.
And as we look ahead at the year ahead for Trinity, our confidence must not only be in the person of
Jesus, but also the work of Jesus. So let's look at that, the work of Jesus. So when Jesus says that
he is going to build his church, what is he talking about? What is this work? What's the
church? If we were to say we're going to build a church here in Fultondale, people will
immediately think, well, is it going to be on Highway 31? Or is it going to be on Walker
Chapel? Like where is it going to be? Because when we use the word church, a lot of people think
a building. And while Jesus used the imagery of building here, when he says church, it's clear
that he's referring to people. The word refers to like an assembly or a gathering of people.
So he's talking about the gathered people of God. It's a people. So we are the church. And
you know, when we began a year ago out at Cornerstone Ranch, that was such a wonderful
reminder to be meeting like outdoors every week. We couldn't make the mistake of thinking the church
was a building because we didn't have one. We were out there in the wide open.
Now buildings can be a useful tool, and I'm grateful for the one that we are in here today.
But we are the church. There's also another important truth here, and that's when we think
about God gathering a people. It also reminds us that Jesus didn't merely come to save
individuals. Now he does that. But he does that to create a new community called the church.
Yes, God draws us individually, but he takes us brick by brick, and he cements us together into
this one house called the church. He unites us in Christ and gets this, and he takes up
residence in that house. God dwells in the midst of his people. You know, the language of a house is
often used in Scripture to speak about where God is dwelling with us. You know, it's used to speak
of creation. We read about the temple of God where God made his dwelling with us. You read that
kind of language when it comes to the new creation. You might think, well, where is God
dwelling today? He's dwelling in the midst of his people, the church. Ephesians 2.22 says,
in him that is in Christ, you are being built together into a dwelling place for God by the
Spirit. So God unites us in Christ, takes up residence in us by his Spirit. He's doing that
globally. He's also doing that in local churches, just like this one. Think of it, the Lord is here
with us even now. But what's the work itself? So he's building this church. What when he says
building that? What's he going to do? Now Jesus has used some pretty triumphant language here
to describe what's coming. You know, he's confirmed that, yeah, he's the king. He's also talked about
building the church on a rock. There's this idea of a strong foundation. He talks about how
nothing's going to stop this work he's going to do. The gates of hell will not prevail
against the church. This picture of strength and security. I couldn't help when I was thinking
about that. Think about when we were at Cornerstone and a fugitive came running through us. Some of you
were there when that happened. And we thought, well, yeah, we've talked about security. It's time
to get some security together. But I actually had a security consultant then meet with me,
I think that week, and we were going to walk around Cornerstone together and have a look at
what needed to be done. And when he pulled up, I felt like I was in a movie because he pulled
up and it was not just his big truck. There were two vans that were behind his truck. And I felt
like a movie, like when the Navy SEALs all arrived and I come pouring out because they opened the doors
of these vans and all of these kind of macho guys and what it looks like kind of military
fatigue kind of got out of the van. And so do you mind if a few friends of mine come and look
at this with you? And so all of us walked around Cornerstone Ranch and they were making
all kinds of suggestions about where all the places we could have security posted. And I
kid you not, one of them was saying like, and the helicopter could land right here in this field.
That would be just the perfect spot for it. So we were going to be the most secure church in Alabama,
no doubt. You can imagine like the disciples hearing all this kind of triumphant language that
Jesus is using about building his church, having that kind of thing in mind. Jesus is going to
build and secure in his church in a way that none of them saw coming. How? Verse 21,
From that time, Jesus began to show his disciples he must go to Jerusalem and suffer
many things from the elders and chief priests and scribes and be killed in all the third day,
be raised. So yes, Jesus is going to build this strong church just as he promised,
but he's going to do that through suffering, through his death, and then through rising again
from the dead. Peter can't stand the thought of that. He takes Jesus society, starts to rebuke him.
Jesus moves from calling Peter blessed to calling him Satan. Jesus says that, you know, Peter's not
being mindful of the things of God, but those that are of man. So humanly speaking, yes, it
makes sense that you would avoid unnecessary suffering and the risk of death. But Jesus is
looking at this from a heavenly perspective. He's fulfilling God's plan to redeem his people.
Note the word must. He began to show his disciples that he must go. He must suffer. He must die
and rise again. So this was inevitable. It was going to happen, but it wasn't
inevitable because he was just such a controversial figure.
It was because of us through Jesus suffering death and resurrection that he would bring about this
new community called the church. It was through his suffering and death that he would rescue us
and bring us into his kingdom. So the truth is that all of us, rather than
gladly living under the reign of such a gracious king, we choose to rebel against him
and go our own way. But God doesn't leave us there. In Christ, we see that he has set his love upon us
and he determines to do what is necessary to save us from sin and death and bring us into his
kingdom. And what is that? Christ, the very King of heaven, laid aside heaven's glory and
took on flesh. He came into this world and lived the perfect life that we failed to live.
And this King, King Jesus, was lifted up not on a throne, but on a cross. And there on the cross,
he died the death that we deserved to die. But then he rose again, having conquered sin and death
and hell. And he ascended to his heavenly throne, having accomplished exactly what he came to do.
And in doing this and suffering, dying and rising again, he secured the salvation of
everyone who puts their trust in him as their Savior and King. Through his death and resurrection,
he secured the building and stability of his church. I love the picture earlier we talked about
how the gates of hell will not prevail against the church. And that was an expression that essentially
referred to the power of death. Here's the idea. Death will not prevail against his people because
he is the one who defeats death in his own death on the cross. As one author put it, he
unlocked the gates of death from the inside. So today, his church is being built by his spirit
when that gospel is proclaimed. People put their trust in him as their King. And all those who are
united to Jesus by faith are united to him in his death and in his resurrection and in his ascension.
And it is our union with Jesus that unites us to one another in the life of the church.
So to undo the church that Jesus is building, you would have to undo what he has already
accomplished. You would have to bring him down from his heavenly throne, and that is impossible.
We are secure in him. He will build his church, and we will be with him forevermore.
So how should we respond to this Jesus who is building his church by way of the cross? We need to put our
confidence also, yes, in the person of Jesus and in his work. We need to trust in the way of Jesus.
So Jesus gives now this open invitation to follow him and to be part of this new community of
disciples that he is creating. And you see that in that last paragraph there in our reading.
He says, follow me. You know, the language of following is used on social media. If you got an
Instagram account, there will be people that you follow there. It's pretty low commitment.
All you have to do is just click that you want to follow them, and boom, you're a follower.
What is involved in following Jesus? Well, there's a greater depth of commitment there.
Jesus says, if anyone will come after me, let him deny himself.
Take up his cross and follow me. So following Jesus involves denying yourself.
That doesn't mean just, I don't know, denying yourself certain things like, you know, denying
yourself chocolate during Lent or something like that. It's denying your very self.
It's laying down the rights to self determination, self dependence, self righteousness.
It's saying, my life is no longer my own. I belong body and soul to Jesus.
He says in a different way, he says, and take up your cross.
You know, having a cross to bear, as far as how Jesus speaks about it here,
isn't kind of how we talk about it today, you know,
so I might have asthma or some allergy or something.
They say, well, you know, we've all got our cross to bear.
That's not what Jesus is saying here.
He's saying, yeah, there's going to be some hardship, but this is far more shocking than the kind of cross
to bear language that we use. Crosses were an instrument of execution.
You would never see it as a piece of jewelry or something like that.
It was a place of death. This is why Dietrich Bonhoeffer,
who was a pastor in Germany during World War II and a martyr,
he said when Jesus calls a man, he bids him come and die.
We're dying to ourselves, giving our lives over to him
with the willingness to follow him wherever he leads.
And here's the thing, if Jesus is truly this king, the sovereign king who reigns over everything
in all of my life, and my life belongs to him, like I should surrender everything to him.
I ought to do that. But if that sovereign king who reigns over everything loves me enough
to lay down his life for me on the cross, then it's not just a matter of I ought to surrender to him.
As we know his love for us, we want to surrender to him, because knowing him and being with him
is far greater than anything else we could ever hold on to.
And so we follow Jesus. You know, this isn't just about what we're leaving behind and denying ourselves.
It's also about what we're getting instead. We're getting Jesus. Jesus and the life we are
giving to him is more precious than anything. Yes, we're crucified with him, but we're also
raised with him. Sure, there will be loss, but there's a far greater gain.
Sure, there's death, but there's life. And that life begins now with Jesus as his apprentice,
joining him as one of his disciples. And that discipleship, that life of discipleship with
Jesus knowing him, is lived together in community. Discipleship happens in community.
We were made to follow Jesus together. You know, I hope this year you've discovered
an eternity fellowship, an authentic caring community. But let me also say this.
It's not just about being part of a community like that, the church. It's about growing
together as followers of Jesus. We're following Jesus together in community.
He's the point. And here's the wonderful thing about that. As we follow him,
as we follow him, he makes us into more of a loving, caring community. That's the best community
you could be part of is one where he is leading. And you know, when we deny ourselves, we take up
our cross and enter into that community that he is building. We don't come like projecting our
desires onto that community, trying to make it what we want it to be. No, we deny ourselves
and we receive the church that Christ is giving us as imperfect as it is. We receive it as a gift
from him. We pray that he would help us to love his people the way he loves them.
Let me just kind of close with this question. What is your next step in following Jesus?
You know, when Trinity fellowship started, we didn't know, seriously, we didn't know
what it was going to be called. We didn't know where we were going to be meeting. We didn't know who
was going to join. Although we knew that the Lord was leading, and he was leading to this
general area, and the Lord has been faithful every step of the way, and he will continue to be
faithful in the year to come. Let's personalize this with you. What is your next step with
him? Maybe surrendering your life to Jesus, maybe even for the first time, to put your trust
in him as your Savior, as your King. Perhaps it's to surrender a fresh to him in order to deny ourselves
daily. Maybe it's to commit to living by his grace among other disciples in the life of the church,
seeking to grow together. Maybe there's a specific area he lays on your heart. But there's this
invitation to join him in this great work he's doing to be part of his community and to follow
him together. So however he leads us collectively and however he leads you personally, let's follow
him knowing that he will build his church. Let's pray. Lord, you are good and faithful.
You are strong and kind. Following you is worth leaving everything for.
So Lord, as you build your church, as you gather your people and dwell in our midst, Lord, I pray that
our trust would be in you and in you alone. Lord, I pray that you would make us eager to be with
one another, to be part of this great work you are doing. And Lord, I pray that you'd make us more
and more willing for you to shape us into your likeness together, even when it's difficult.
Or with open hands, Lord, I pray that we would be ready to take us wherever you would lead.
And may you receive all the glory for it. We ask this in your name. Amen.